- Well, we're both single parents.
- Yes.
- That can be,
you know what it is?
It can be taxing I feel like.
But what is your take on it,
like as far as single parenting?
I'm interested.
- It's tough.
I think, you know, reshaping
a family is tricky.
And the one benefit is it's allowed
for some really deep
conversations with my kids,
like about emotions and about happiness
and about what family means and love.
And it's actually allowed
me to get to know them
in a different way.
You know, my priority is them.
- Amen.
- Like, that's what it is.
It's as long as they're happy
and they're healthy then,
you know, my ex and I, we agree on that.
They are everything to us.
And I think that, you know,
there's so many families who are blended
and different shapes-
- Oh my god, I'm from one,
and I have one right now.
It's hard.
- It's hard, but I just-
- But it's doable.
- It's doable.
Like, if you can surround
them with so much love,
then it's okay.
But you know, it's tricky
'cause we're not doing
it in private.